Ja, im Prinzip folgt das recht ähnlichen Prinzipien wie Bitcoin selbst, also es verwendet ein peer-to-peer-Netzwerk. Anders als Bitcoin verwenden wir Tor, es integriert in der Application, also der User muss da nichts installieren. Und Tor, ihr habt vorher schon über Tor geredet, meine Meinung zu Tor ist, es ist einfach ein Privacy- und Security-Layer zum Internet. Das ist im Prinzip wie HTTPS, was jeder verwendet, wenn er zur Bank-Webpage surft. Ähnlich ist eigentlich Tor. Es hat nur bessere und höhere Sicherheit und Privacy. Aber zurück zum Thema. Ja, weil der User das installiert hat, ist er verbunden mit allen anderen BitSquare-Usern und kann entweder ein Offer machen, dass er jetzt Bitcoin gegen Euro zum Beispiel umtauschen will, oder er kann ein bestehendes Offer nehmen, was er in einer Liste in der Application dann sieht. Ja, dann sobald er eben einen Trade startet mit einem anderen User, muss der, der den Bitcoin verkaufen will, muss den Bitcoin einzahlen auf eine spezielle Adresse, das ist eine Multisig-Adresse. Das ist etwas Spezielles im Bitcoin, das ist im Prinzip so etwas wie eine Lockbox. Da kann man definieren, wie viele Eigentümer mehr oder weniger es gibt für diese Adresse und wie viele Eigentümer man braucht, um das Geld, das auf der Adresse ist, auszuzahlen. Wir verwenden eine 2-of-3-Multisig, das heißt, man braucht mindestens zwei der drei Beteiligten, damit man das Geld wieder rausbekommt. Normalerweise sind das die zwei Leute, die den Exchange machen. Wenn am Schluss alles gut gegangen ist, dann können die beide das vereinbaren, dass das Geld dann ausbezahlt wird, auf den, der das Bitcoin kaufen will. Wenn irgendwas schief geht, entweder aus technischen Problemen oder weil einer den anderen betrügen will oder die Bank Probleme gemacht hat bei der Überweisung, dann gibt es diese dritte Person, das ist ein Arbitrator oder ein Schiedsrichter oder Customer Care Agent, der sich dann den Fall anschaut und der dann mit beiden kommuniziert und der muss dann herausfinden, was schiefgegangen ist und wem das Geld zusteht.
Ich versuche mal zusammenzufassen. Also jemand hat einen Bitcoin, also man kann die Währung unterteilen, wenn du das nur für theoretisch nennen willst. Jemand hat einen Bitcoin und schreibt quasi in der Software, was so eine Art Auktionsplattform für virtuelle Währung zu sein scheint, schreibt, ich möchte einen Bitcoin verkaufen. Wer bietet mir dafür 100 Euro? Und dann kann ich sagen, okay, ich mache das. Oder es ist umgedreht, ich sage, ich habe 100 Euro. Wer will mir dafür einen Bitcoin verkaufen? Und dann kommunizieren wir über die App und dann überweise ich, also dann sagt der Typ, ich zahle das ein auf so eine Art Sicherheitskonto. Ich überweise dem auf herkömmlichen Wege irgendwie diese 100 Euro. Und dann sagen beide, das ist okay. Und dann wird mir der Bitcoin übertragen.
Ja genau, also die Überweisung von der Fiat-Währung, also von Euro zum Beispiel, die geht dann ganz normal klassisch über die Banken. Also du bekommst über die Software die Kontonummer vom Bitcoin-Käufer und gehst dann auf deinen Online-Konto, machst die Überweisung, machst eine Confirmation in der Application, die Nachricht muss dann nachschauen, ob er das Geld erhalten hat. Das kann natürlich leider ein paar Tage dauern, weil die Banken jetzt nicht langsam sind, was völlig unverständlich ist heutzutage. Aber sobald der Bitcoin-Verkäufer die Euro erhalten hat, bestätigt er das in der Software und damit wird dann diese Auszahlungstransaktion gemacht von diesen gesperrten Bitcoins. Und der Bitcoin-Käufer bekommt seine Bitcoins. Das ist eigentlich der Basis.
Jetzt hast du aber gesagt, es gibt so eine Art Schiedsrichter, der guckt, ob das alles in recht der Dinge geht und wenn er irgendwie beschissen ist oder technische Probleme, kann er es erklären. Wo sitzt dieser Schiedsrichter? Wer ist das?
Ja, das ist momentan... Also das wird auch ein dezentrales System sein, das ist momentan noch nicht implementiert, weil das noch ein bisschen aufwendig ist. Aber prinzipiell kann jeder so ein Arbitrator werden. Der muss aber einen gewissen Geldbetrag hinterlegen, auch in so einem Multisig. Und es gibt eine gewisse Hierarchie von Arbitratern. Also die Arbitrator, die am meisten Geld hinterlegt haben und die am längsten dabei sind, also die am meisten Reputation haben, die haben dann ein höheres Gewicht. Die sind zum Beispiel die Keyholder von diesem Multisig, wo dieses Depostet einbezahlt wird von neuen Arbitrator. Und der Arbitrator schaut sich das an, hat ein bisschen wie ein Customer Care Job. Also der bekommt ein gewisses Rulebook, wie er arbeiten muss und was er befolgen muss. Ja, also das ist noch nicht ganz geklärt, aber für BitSquare ist eine neue Organisationsform geplant, also eine Art virtuelle Aktiengesellschaft. Also Decentralized Autonomous Organization ist der Begriff, der in der Kryptowelt dafür verwendet wird. Das ist ein nächstes Subprojekt, das wahrscheinlich bald entwickelt wird. Und damit werden alle Leute, die für BitSquare arbeiten, mit der Eigentümer vom Projekt und bekommen dann die Trading Fees bezahlt als Lohn. Also sind einfach wie bei einer AG-Shareholder. Und desto mehr Share sie haben, desto höher reingenehm werden sie bekommen. Und die Leute, die dafür arbeiten, bekommen für die Arbeit neue Shares ausbezahlt.
Das heißt sozusagen, im Prinzip, wenn ich mich da hinsetze und diesen Job mache, dann kriege ich dafür Geld aus Transaktionsgebühren. Jetzt ist ja der Mensch grundsätzlich schlecht und da würde ich mir denken, so okay, wenn ich so was mache, dann spreche ich mich einfach mit jemanden ab, der Bitcoin verkauft, bin ja selber Arbitrader und dann kann man da schön Beschiss machen.
Genau, aber dafür musst du eben am Anfang relativ hohe Summe hinterlegen. Das wären so ungefähr 5-10 Bitcoins sind. Das sind 2-5.000 Euro und die werden, die sind gelockt mit den Keys von den Arbitratern mit der höchsten Reputation. Das sind auch Arbitrater, die mit dem Projekt direkt verbunden sind. Das bin ich zum Beispiel. Also ich werde nicht irgendeinen, einen User betrügen und mein eigenes Projekt ruinieren oder andere Leute.
Wer weiß. Okay, aber man muss schon so eine Art Grundvertrauen in das Projekt haben, wenigstens.
Ja, ich glaube, es erledigt sich wirklich, weil das, was der Arbitrator maximal stehlen kann bei einem Trade, also die Trades sind immer limitiert auf momentan maximal zwei Bitcoin. Das sind ungefähr 1000 Euro. Das heißt, maximal 1000 Euro stehlen, wenn dann der zweite Arbitrator, der schaut sich das an. Also wenn...
Also ich kann sagen, ich kann nie mehr Euro klauen in einem Mal, als ich eh eingezahlt und hinterlegt habe.
Genau, du wirst auf jeden Fall verlieren. Und dann wird, wenn ihm solche, also der andere Trader, der sich ungerecht behandelt fühlt, der wird sich dann beschwerden. Dann werden sich diese High Reputation Arbitrator, den Fall noch mehr anschauen, wenn die draufkommen. Der Arbitrator hat betrogen, verliert erst ein ganzes Deposit und hat viel mehr verloren, wie er gewinnen kann. So, das ist das Grundkonzept. Detail sind dann noch komplex auf jeden Fall, aber da haben wir nicht die Zeit dazu wahrscheinlich.
Ich wollte noch kurz fragen, wieso benutzt ihr Tor und was ist der Effekt, Tor zu nutzen? Also ist es ein Hidden Service BitSquare oder?
Ja, eigentlich der Hauptgrund, warum ich, ich hab früher andere das Peer-to-Peer-Netzwerk verwendet, der Distributed Hashtable, das hat aber leider nie gut funktioniert im echten Internet, weil es, also die große Hürde für Peer-to-Peer-Netzwerke sind die Firewalls und die Natural Versions, also die Probleme, die man mit den verschiedenen Setups von verschiedenen Computern hat, dass man erreichbar ist für andere User. Und ich wollte nicht, dass die Leute dann selbst irgendwas konfigurieren müssen mit einem Router oder so, damit sie die Software verwenden können. Das heißt, ich brauchte eine Lösung, die einfach zum installieren ist und funktioniert. Und Tor ist einfach eine super Lösung, weil die kommen über jede Firewall.
Also diese Trading-Plattform ist gar keine Webseite, sondern das ist die Software, die über Tor miteinander kommuniziert?
Es ist eine Desktop-Application. Es ist in Java implementiert und Tor ist integriert in der Application. Man muss nicht Tor installieren oder irgendwas konfigurieren. Das kommt alles mit der Application und bei Default hat man Tor. Und dadurch ist man nicht mit seiner IP-Adresse sichtbar zu irgendein anderem Netzwerk. Man hat eigentlich maximale Privacy-Themen mit der jetzigen IP-Adresse, mehr oder weniger. Ja, maximale ist nicht mehr relativ, aber das ist wahrscheinlich eine der besten Lösungen für Privacy-Themen.
Dennis hat auch noch eine Frage.
Ja, und zwar, wenn du meinst, hier du bist der Oberarbitrator, ist das dann nicht das ganze System doch wieder so ganz schön zentral?
Ja, ich bin nicht der Oberarbitrator. Das führt dann in eine Gruppe. Es wird einfach so eine Hierarchie sein. Und es ist ein bisschen ähnlich wie das legale System mit den Supreme Courts, mit den obersten Gerichtshöfen, irgendwo.
Aber das ist doch dann sehr zentral, weil dann der oberste Gerichtshof ist sehr, sehr zentral.
Genau, der Trade selbst, der Arbitrator, weiß gar nichts davon. Er bekommt, er ist nur quasi, es wird nur sein Key verwendet zum Erstellen dieser Multisig, aber er ist nicht aktiver Bestandteil vom Trade. Nur wenn ein Problem auftaucht, dann brauchen wir sichere Lösungen, wie wir das Problem lösen. Und da ist dann der Dezentralisationsaspekt, ja, wir haben zumindest noch keine bessere Lösung gefunden, wie diese, dass wir so ein hierarchisches System haben. Und irgendwo muss man aufhören. Natürlich könnte man dann irgendwo hergehen.
Aber noch so sagen, als letzter Frage, wie viele sozusagen oberste wird es geben?
Also Details, nachdem dieses dezentrale System noch nicht implementiert ist, die sind noch nicht alle völlig ausgearbeitet. Also das Grundkonzept ist, dass es eine größere Gruppe ist von 10 bis 20 Leuten, die teilweise für BitSquare arbeiten oder die teilweise persönlich bekannt sind, wo ich einfach weiß, die sind keine Betrüger. Und die Incentives funktionieren ja, weil diese Leute, die für BitSquare arbeiten, wenn die jetzt irgendwo andere Users kämen, erzeugen ja viel mehr Schaden, wie sie eigentlich verdienen über die Plattform, wenn sie dafür arbeiten und das Projekt erfolgreich wird.
Wir müssen leider zum Schluss kommen, weil wir sagen noch ein paar andere Themen, schauen wir mal an. Einen spannenden Ansatz auf jeden Fall zu sagen, dass man die Verwandlung ins, wie heißt es, Viat-Geld, also das echte Geld, auch dezentral organisieren kann.
Ich hatte noch eine ganz kurze Frage.
Wir haben gerade jetzt mit der letzten Version Statistiken eingebaut, weil es auch nicht so trivial in einem peer-to-peer-System ist. Und es wird aber ein bisschen dauern, bis das alle Use abgedetet haben, bis wir halbwegs vernünftige Statistiken haben. Aber es ist noch, also seit April ist es live und es ist halt noch in Bootstrapping, also kann jetzt nicht wirklich...
Wie viel Volumen meinst du, wie viele Bitcoins da umgesetzt werden? Na gut, sind wir dann sehr gespannt. Manfred, dir auf jeden Fall vielen Dank für die Erläuterung. So, und dann haben wir tatsächlich noch einen Hörer anruf und zwar den Christopher aus Oranienburg. Hallo und guten Abend, Christopher.
Moin leschön.
Du hattest eine Frage zu Bitcoin noch.
Zu dem Manfred direkt, zu seinem Projekt hatte ich eigentlich eine Frage.
Ist der Manfred noch da?
Deutschland ist ja nun mal die größte Exchange zurzeit Bitcoin.de. Die haben ja einen Pakt, sag ich jetzt mal, mit der Speedo-Bank eingegangen. Dadurch ist es möglich, sozusagen Bitcoin als Blitzüberweisung auszuführen, was mir persönlich sehr gut gefällt, weil ich hab schon oft das Erlebnis gehabt, man überweist, das dauert, das dauert, das dauert, der Bitcoin fällt ins Unermessliche, dann hat man ihn endlich und ist nur noch die Hälfte wert. Ist da im Plan irgendwie eine Möglichkeit zu finden, auch so etwas zu gestalten?
Also längerfristig wollen wir Bank oder Payment Provider APIs integrieren, aber da kommen leider nur ganz moderne Firmen in Frage und da gibt es halt nur ganz wenige im Bankenbereich oder im Paymentbereich. Also ich kenne nur OKB und Perfect Money, die APIs anbieten, wo man in der Application dann direkt einen Kontauch für Euro oder sowas hat und dann die Transaktion automatisieren kann. Dann kann alles viel schneller ablaufen, weil dann nicht der User handysch irgendwie online gehen muss und bestätigen muss und so weiter. Und wenn der nicht am Computer sitzt, dauert es ein paar Stunden. Leider mit normalen Bankengebieten keine APIs anbieten und ich glaube, das wird auch nicht in Kürze passieren. Also da bin ich sehr pessimistisch, weil ich meine, die könnten das seit mehr als 10 Jahren machen, wie alle normalen Internetprojekte oder Firmen das machen, aber das Leben halt in 80 Jahren. Und das sehe ich auch keine große Bewegung. Immer mit modernen Payment- oder Fintech-Firmen, wie diese Number 26, das ist auf jeden Fall interessant. Die werden wir vermutlich auch bald integrieren und dann mehr und mehr versuchen, dass dann die Leute dazwischen, weil man kann den Transfer von Fiat um einiges beschleunigen, wenn es die gleiche Firma oder die gleiche Bank ist. Dann geht es alles wirklich instant, wie bei OKB. Oder eben wenn es auch die gleiche Bank ist, geht es in manchen Ländern zumindest auch instant. Und das werden wir auf jeden Fall mehr unterstützen. Momentan haben wir halt nur die wichtigsten Sachen, wie SEPA und nationalen Payment-Transfers, damit das weltweit funktioniert.
Ich glaube, der Bedarf, der Bitcoin Nutzer, ich kenne jetzt nicht viele Bitcoin Nutzer, ich glaube, der Großteil der Bitcoin Nutzer legt schon Wert darauf, dass diese Transaktionen schnell über die Bühne gehen. Von daher glaube ich, dass es wünschenswert ist. Ansonsten unterstütze ich die Idee, also das wird super, ich bin nochmal so am Rande.
Also bei OKB, bei diesen Payment-Methoden, wo wir wissen, dass sie instant möglich sind, ist es nur ein Tag Zeitfenster im BitSquare, wo die User die Transaktion abwickeln müssen. Ansonsten geht es dann zum Arbitrator. Und der, der zu langsam war, verliert dann ein bisschen was an Geld. Aber leider bei normalen Banken wie bei SEPA kann es teils 3-4 Tage dauern. Und wenn es eine lange Woche ist, dauert es insgesamt 7 Tage. Da sind wir leider an dieses alte System gebunden und können nichts Besseres machen, weil sonst die liefern.
Alles klar, Christoph, ich hoffe, das hat deine Frage beantwortet.
Ich glaube, ab 2017, vielleicht aber auch ein Jahr später, ich bin mir nicht so sicher, gibt es auch neue Auflagen für die Banken, dann muss das alles sehr, sehr schnell gehen mit den Überweisungen.
Was heißt sehr schnell? 24 Stunden? 6? 2? Eine?
Minuten.
Minuten?
Ja, oder noch schneller.
Weiß jemand von euch, warum das so lange dauert? Also hat die Bank irgendwas davon?
Die verwenden teils wirklich noch Mainframes. Ich hab zwei Programmiererkennende von der Uni. Einer hat eben noch Mainframe, der war noch Mainframe-Programmierer. Er war wahrscheinlich der einzige, den sie gefunden haben. Und die Bank der einzige Job, den er gefunden hat. Die verwenden wirklich noch Systeme aus den 70, 80 Jahren. Das ist halt super langsam. Das andere Hauptproblem ist, glaube ich, Chargeback. Dass das Settlement einfach sehr kompliziert ist, weil man nie sicher ist, wenn das Geld wirklich sicher ist und nicht zurückgefordert werden kann. Ich glaube bei SEPA hat man ein halbes Jahr. Das ist natürlich ein Wahnsinn.
Alles klar, verrückt. Hoffen wir, dass es irgendwann mal schneller wird. Ich würde es mir über uns auch wünschen. So, Mainframe, dann aber jetzt wirklich vielen Dank und viel Glück mit BitSquare noch. Ich bin sehr gespannt, wo das hingeht. So, und jetzt habt ihr euch vielleicht gefragt, der Richter hat doch jedes Mal, wenn die Sendung aufgemacht, auch den Christian begrüßt. Warum ist der denn eigentlich hier? Naja, also es gibt, jetzt sag ich wieder was, was wahrscheinlich gleich auch wieder großen Aufschrei verursachen wird. Aber in meiner Wahrnehmung, als jemand, der nicht allzu viel Ahnung hat, es gibt sozusagen ein Projekt und das kommt bei mir so an, wie das ist jetzt das neue Bitcoin. Das heißt Ethereum oder Ethereum oder irgendwie so und ist anscheinend auch was, was wie Bitcoin funktioniert, so ist es bei mir zumindest angekommen. Christian, du arbeitest an diesem Projekt mit, bist damit involviert. Was genau ist das? Ist es wie Bitcoin oder nicht?
Also es benutzt die die gleiche Technologie, die gleiche grundlegende Technologie, also diese Blockchain Technologie, die wir vorhin auch erklärt haben.
Also Blockchain heißt dieses sagen, jemand macht was und alle gucken zu und schreiben auf, was er gemacht hat.
Genau so ist es ja. Aber Bitcoin hat als Anwendungsfall sozusagen Überweisungen tätigen und da funktioniert es auch sehr gut und das wollen wir auch gar nicht ersetzen. Was Ethereum macht ist, dem ganzen System noch eine Datenbank hinzufügen und Programme hinzufügen. Wir hatten ja vorhin das Beispiel mit dem Buch, das in der Bank liegt. Man muss der Bank vertrauen, dass er dieses Buch richtig führt. Bei Ethereum gibt es auch so ein Buch, das dezentral verwaltet wird. Da kann man nicht nur Kontostände damit verwalten, sondern es ist eine richtige Datenbank. Software kann auf diese Datenbank zugreifen und die Daten verändern, mit der Daten etwas machen. Während die Software das tut, können alle zuschauen und kontrollieren, dass das mit richtigen Dingen funktioniert.
Was Bitcoin eigentlich macht, ist, es stellt eine Liste mit Zahlen und sagt dann, also Zahl 1 gehört jetzt User X, Zahl 2 gehört User Y, Zahl 3 gehört User und so weiter und so fort. Alle gucken zu, alle schreiben beim Anruf, aber man weiß im Prinzip kann man nur das machen, man kann diese Blöcke, Briefmarken, Zahlen hin und her schieben. Jetzt sagst du, Serum ist so was ähnliches, aber da stecken einfach mehr Daten drin.
Also vielleicht kann ich mal ein paar Beispiele geben, was man machen kann und zwar genauso, man kann wie bei Bitcoin auch die Währung verschieben. Es kann sich aber auch jeder ganz einfach eine eigene Währung erzeugen, die dann auf diesem System funktioniert und man kann Daten verwalten, wie zum Beispiel ein Grundbuch, ein Grundstückregister. Das heißt, ich kann in diese Datenmark rein schreiben, also wenn ein Staat zustimmt, das Grundbuch so zu verwalten, dann könnte man das über dieses System machen und man kann eben auch das durch Programme verwalten lassen. Und dann kann man beispielsweise sagen, es gibt ein Programm, das auf Ethereum läuft, das komplett dezentral verwaltet wird, das eine Auktion darstellt. Das heißt, ich kann dezentral Auktionen durchführen lassen über diese Daten in der Datenbank.
Ich muss ganz ehrlich sagen, ich verstehe es immer noch. Ich wollte gerade sagen, verstehst du das?
Ja, also ich probiere es mal. Und zwar ist ja bei Bitcoin ist es so, da werden ja auch nicht die Zahlen verwaltet, sondern jede Transaktion ist so ein kleines Skript, was sagt, diese Bitcoin bitte von da nach da schieben. Das heißt, diese Skripte sind sehr transaktionsbasiert. Wenn ich das richtig verstehe, weil ich kenne mich mit Ethereum auch nicht so aus, dann bei Ethereum sind auch Skripte, aber die sind wesentlich komplexer und man kann da auch noch andere Sachen mit machen als nur Transaktionen oder Zahlen verschieben. Ist das ungefähr richtig?
Also man hat einen Key-Value-Store, man kann Sachen abspeichern.
Ich liebe es, wenn das ein paar... Alles sogar einfach zum Key-Value-Store. Also okay, ich versuche es nochmal zu verstehen. Ich versuche es mal andersrum zu erklären oder ich versuche es mal andersrum zu verstehen. Also es gibt ja Programme so in der normalen Welt. Also wir beschreiben Programme sind sozusagen Teilen von Code und die werden dann ausgeführt von einem Computer. Und Ethereum ist das jetzt sozusagen, es gibt ein Programm, aber das ist da irgendwie hinterlegt und dann gucken alle, ob es das macht, was es soll oder so?
Genau, also durch diese Technologie ist es praktisch so, dass sozusagen ein globaler Computer geschaffen wird, der von jedem benutzt werden kann und der von jedem auch kontrolliert werden kann.
Also jeder kann da ein Programm reinstellen in diesen globalen Computer und dann ist es nicht Distributed Computing, sondern Decentralized Computing. Das heißt, jeder Rechner im Netzwerk führt das gleiche Programm zur gleichen Zeit auf gleiche Art und Weise aus und das Ergebnis wird dann auf die gleiche Art und Weise von all diesen Rechnern in einen Block getan und der, der den Zuschlag kriegt, dass sein Block genommen wird, der Block landet dann in der Blockchain und da stehen dann all die Daten, also der State von dem Programm steht da dann drin.
Ok, also als Beispiel, es gibt ein Programm, das rechnet aus, wer der schlauste Mensch im ganzen Land ist.
Man könnte ein Voting, ein Voting ist glaube ich ein gutes Beispiel.
Darf ich nochmal so etwas zufassen? Ok, es gibt ein Programm, das findet raus sozusagen, dass er rechnet, wer ist der schlauste Mensch im ganzen Land. Wenn das nur auf meinem Rechner läuft, dann sagt Marcus Richter, völlig klar, dann ist sozusagen berechtigter Zweifel, dass er sagt, ja, vielleicht hat er das Programm beeinflusst, das stimmt eigentlich nicht so. Was Ethereum macht, ist, es schickt das Programm auf jeden Rechner der Teilnehmenden, stellt also sicher, dass auf jedem Rechner das Programm genauso abläuft, wie es abgegeben wurde und vergleicht dann die Ergebnisse aller Computer, die das Programm ausgeführt haben und sagt dann, die kriegen alle Marcus Richter raus, das Ergebnis muss stimmen.
Nee, die vergleichen auch nicht mal. Die müssen gar nicht miteinander vergleichen, weil die kriegen alle das gleiche Ergebnis raus. Und wenn da Programm dabei ist, was ein anderes Ergebnis rausfindet, dann ist das nicht der echte Ethereum-Client oder bei Bitcoin, das ist kein echter Bitcoin-Client und dann löst sich das vom Netzwerk ab und macht nicht mehr mit.
Okay, aber dadurch, dass das Programm auf jedem Rechner durchgeführt wird, das heißt, der Ergebnis, deswegen wird das Ergebnis dann als korrekt angenommen.
Genau, also ich meine, bei herkömmlichen Web-Server-Software, wenn ich bei Google irgendwie ein Dokument hoch lade, dann lade ich das hoch, dann läuft auf dem Google-Server natürlich auch Software und ich kann aber nicht nachvollziehen, was diese Software in meinem Dokument macht, ob das Dokument irgendwie abgeändert wird. Und bei Ethereum ist es eben so, dass es keinen einzelnen Server gibt, auf dem diese Software läuft, sondern es läuft verteilt auf allen gleichzeitig und damit kann jeder nachvollziehen, was passiert und auch sichergehen, dass genau das passiert, was man denkt.
Damit alle wieder auf dem gleichen Stand sind.
Also jeder muss ja wissen, so eine Art sichere Cloud, also transparente Cloud, weil jeder sehen kann, was darin vorgeht. Aber zumindest eine, wo nichts gefälscht werden kann. Also wo ich dann immer sicher sein kann, okay, was ich da raus bekomme, ist sozusagen das, was ich reingetan habe. Und wenn nicht, dann sehe ich, was verändert wurde.
Genau.
Ja, Mann, jetzt muss ich jetzt ein bisschen... So, ich muss jetzt erst mal sacken lassen. Die höre wahrscheinlich auch. Deswegen gibt es jetzt eine kleine Musik von Ronnie Friedman, die heißt Arms. Und dann reden wir weiter über Ethereum, den Supercomputer in der Cloud. Ha, ich hab's nochmal gesagt. Okay, kannst du gleich nochmal richtig erklären.
Ja.
Bundeskanzlerin Merkel hat die jüngsten Terroranschläge in Deutschland als zivilisatorischen Tabubruch bezeichnet. Offensichtlich wollen die Terroristen den Zusammenhalt der Gesellschaft zerstören, sagte die Kanzlerin in ihrer vorgezogenen Sommerpressekonferenz. Deutschland werde aber auch weiterhin politisch verfolgten Asyl gewähren. Die Kanzlerin kündigte auch einen neuen Punkteplan gegen islamistischen Extremismus an. Dazu soll ein besseres Frühwarnsystem vor möglichen Radikalisierungen gehören. Und es sollen Vorbereitungen getroffen werden, dass die Bundeswehr bei großen Terroranschlägen auch im Inland eingesetzt werden kann. Auch die bayerische Landesregierung verschärft nach den drei Gewalttaten innerhalb von einer Woche ihre Sicherheitspolitik. So sollen bis 2020 insgesamt 2000 neue Polizisten eingestellt und die Videoüberwachung z.B. an Bahnhöfen ausgeweitet werden. Außerdem wird der Wunsch nach einer Grundgesetzänderung formuliert. Dadurch soll der Einsatz der Bundeswehr im Inland bei Anschlaggefahren erleichtert werden. Zwischen der Türkei und Deutschland bahnt sich neuer Streit an. Die Türkei fordert von Deutschland 4500 Anhänger der Gülen-Bewegung auszuliefern. Präsident Erdogan macht den Prädigal Gülen für den Putschversuch vor zwei Wochen verantwortlich. Tausende mutmaßliche Anhänger wurden seitdem in der Türkei festgenommen oder ihre Ämter beim Militär, in der Justiz oder im Medienbereich enthoben. Das Verhältnis zwischen Deutschland und der Türkei ist bereits durch die Armenien-Resolution des Bundestages stark belastet. Darin wird das Massaker an den Armenien im Osmanischen Reich als Völkermord bezeichnet. Fußball-Bundesliga ist Hertha BSC, ist nach 6, 5 Jahren zurück auf der europäischen Fußballbühne. Die Berliner gewannen das Hinspiel in der dritten Runde der Europa League Qualifikation gegen das dänische Team von Brönnspi IF mit 1 zu 0. Das Siegtor schoss Ibisevic in der 28. Minute. Das Rückspiel findet am 4. August in Kopenhagen statt. Die aktuellen Temperaturen liegen in Berlin Marzahn bei 19, in Tegel bei 21 Grad. Küritz hat 17 Grad, Cottbus 18 Grad, Manchnow 19 Grad und Ludwigsfelde 20 Grad. In der Nacht ziehen von Südwesten vereinzelte Schauer oder Gewitter ran. Teilweise sind auch kräftige Starkregen mit dabei und es kühlt sich ab auf bis zu 16 Grad. Morgens lassen dann die Schauer nach. Es lockert auf und es wird recht freundlich mit Sonne und Wolken im Wechsel bei maximal 26 Grad. Erst am Abend kann es dann wieder neue Schauer geben. Mit dem Stadtverkehr Berlin in Charlottenburg. Die Kahnstraße zwischen New-Achimsthaler-Straße und Fasanenstraße ist gesperrt. Ein Kran-Einsatz ist dort bis morgen früh um 3 Uhr im Gange. Und in Friedrichshain an der Ostbahn in Höhe am Vrietzner Bahnhof ist ebenfalls ein Kran im Einsatz. Außerdem gibt es eine Nachtbaustelle und dort ist eine Sperrung bis um 5 Uhr früh. Außerdem gibt es immer noch Sperrungen wegen der Überschwemmungen. In Gesundbrunn ist der Gleimtunnel betroffen und in Schöneberg die Hohenstaufenstraße zwischen Martin Luther und Münchner Straße. In Brandenburg, Vorsicht auf der A20 Rostock Richtung Berlin, im Kreuz Uckermark zwischen Prenzlau-Süd und Kreuz Uckermark sind Leute auf der Standspur. Dort bitte aufpassen. Und auf der A24 Hamburg Richtung Berlin zwischen Dreieck-Wittstock-Dosse und Dreieck-Hafelland ist ein Schwertransporter unterwegs und darf nicht überholt werden. Ansonsten überall gute Fahrt.
Fritz ist eine Produktion des RBB.
Und wenn ihr Fritz im Live- oder Musikstream hören wollt, dann geht doch mal auf fritz.de slash streambox.
Hallo und willkommen zurück zu einer letzten halben Stunde Chaosradio im Blumen auf Fritz, wo es heute um digitales Geld geht. Also eigentlich, wie wir mittels dieses Internets, von dem wir mal reden und was ich bestimmt gar nicht durchsetzen wird, Währungsrepräsentationen von einem Punkt zum anderen verschieben können und noch ein bisschen mehr, wie ich gerade gelernt habe. Wir haben schon geredet über wie man Kreditkarten sozusagen in Zukunft, in welche Geräte man die reinstecken kann, was mit den Dingen ist, mit so Online-Diensten, die Portale sind, wo man sein Geld verschieben kann und die das irgendwie bei sich behalten, über Bitcoins und jetzt über Ethereum oder Ethereum oder das haben wir noch gar nicht geredet. Wie spricht man das denn eigentlich wirklich aus Dennis, Dirk und Christian? Wie heißt das?
Im Englischen würde ich Ethereum sagen, im Deutschen kann man Ethereum sagen oder Ethereum oder... Ich spreche darüber nicht so viel, aber auf Deutsch deswegen.
Die Währung heißt dann Ether, glaube ich.
Also die eine Währung. Man kann ja mehrere Währungen machen, habe ich gelernt schon.
Es gibt eine Hauptwährung, deren Hauptzweck ist, diese Transaktionsgebühren zu bezahlen, die bei Ethereum genauso anfangen oder auf eine ähnliche Art und Weise anfangen, wie bei Bitcoin.
Okay, wir haben ja schon gelernt, dass Ethereum nicht nur eine Währung ist, sondern es ist quasi eine Art großer Computer, wo alle, die bei Ethereum mitmachen, das Programm einmal bei sich laufen lassen. Dadurch hat man das Ergebnis mehrfach ausgerechnet und weiß dann auch, dass es stimmt. Also dass da kein Schmuck passiert ist. Was macht man damit jetzt? Gibt es da schon Anwendungszwecke? Ich hatte als Beispiel eine Computer-Programm rechnen, aus der ich der schlauste Mensch der Welt ist. Ich vermute, das ist nicht der Zweck für Ethereum. Was macht man damit?
Also bis jetzt? Anwendungen, die man schon so richtig in der Hand halten kann, gibt es noch nicht so richtig. Das liegt auch daran, weil so richtig nützliche Sachen brauchen immer so eine Schnittstelle in der realen Welt. Und die ist halt immer ein bisschen schwieriger, was wir ja auch bei den decentralized exchanges gesehen haben. Aber also Sachen innerhalb von Ethereum oder innerhalb der Cryptocurrency-Welt sind viel leichter zu machen. Und was zurzeit relativ beliebt ist und auch schon gemacht wird, sind so eine Art Crowdfunding mit einer Beteiligungsfunktion durch Wahlen.
Erklär, genauer.
Genau, das nennt man also decentralized autonomous organization, ist das Schlagwort. Und da geht es eben darum, dass jeder, also man schafft so einen Pool und jeder kann da sein Geld reingeben. Und abhängig von der Menge an Geld, die man reingegeben hat, hat man dann ein Stimmrecht innerhalb dieser Organisation. Und dann wird durch Wahlen bestimmt, was mit dem Geld gemacht wird, oder insgesamt, wie diese Organisation agieren soll.
Also eine Aktiengesellschaft.
Ja, Aktiengesellschaft ist eine strenge Auflage, aber es ist ähnlich zu einer Aktiengesellschaft.
Man hat nicht unbedingt Dividenden zum Beispiel. Also im Prinzip ist ja eine Firma, Leute pumpen da Geld rein, dann gehört ihnen das zu gewissen Anteilen, dann dürfen sie bestimmen, was da passiert. Warum braucht man da Ethereum dazu?
Weil jeder, also genau, bei einer Aktiengesellschaft gibt es diese Aktionärsversammlungen, aber Kleinanleger gehen da nicht hin. Das heißt, sie...
Doch, für die Schnittchen.
Im Normalfall können die ihr Stimmrecht gar nicht wahrnehmen. Bei Ethereum, das ist halt eine Software, da abstimmen ist ein Klick und da kann jeder teilnehmen.
Die können ihr Stimmrecht eben, also bei den normalen Aktiengeschaften nicht wahrnehmen, weil sie nicht dürfen oder weil es keine Rolle spielt?
Nein, weil man sich physikalisch an einen Ort begeben muss, wo man dann abstimmen kann.
Das ist für die zu aufwendig. Die Stimme ist nur ein Millionzelt Teilwert, zählt wahrscheinlich im Einzelnen eh nix, und dann irgendwo hinfahren ist Quatsch. Und da soll das umgesetzt werden, weil das ist nur ein Klick am Computer, und dann kann man das eher machen. Genau. Und das ist jetzt ein Plan, den man umsetzen will, oder das gibt es schon?
Das gibt es schon, ja.
Und wofür wurde das schon benutzt?
Oder ich sag mal, ja, also...
Das ist gerade ein Wunderpunkt.
Ja, das ist gerade so ein bisschen ein Wunderpunkt. Das ist so ein bisschen schiefgegangen, sag ich mal.
Ich bin ja großer Fan von Fehlerkultur, weil alles was schiefgegangen ist, daraus kann man was lernen. Was ist genau passiert?
Es gab einen... Also, genau, wie haben wir schon gesagt, jeder kann solche Programme erstellen, d.h. man muss Software schreiben. Und Software kann natürlich Fehler haben. Und in dieser Software gab es einen Fehler.
Also in dieser Software, die diese Gesellschaft, diesen Gesellschaftsdruck darstellt, dieses DAO, was soll das sein?
Genau so ist es.
Okay, da war ein Fehler drin, der wozu geführt hat?
Der hat dazu geführt, dass man Geld auf eine Weise abziehen konnte, die so nicht geplant war. Und das wurde dann auch getan.
Und das eigentliche Problem war, dass da auch ganz viel Geld drin steckte, womit eigentlich auch vorher keiner gerechnet hat.
Also es gibt dieses Ding, dieses Ding funktioniert, dass man sozusagen etwas von der virtuellen Währung da reintut und dann kriegt man Stimmrechnungen. Da war jetzt viel Geld drin und dann hat das jemand da rausziehen können, indem er was getan hat, indem er einfach ein fehlerhaftes Programm geschrieben hat.
Ja, also man musste das Programm, also man musste eigentlich, man musste noch ein weiteres Programm erstellen, das dann mit dem DAO-Programm interagiert hat auf eine bestimmte Art und Weise. Und es war schon relativ kompliziert, das durchzuführen.
Und dann ist was passiert?
Dann ist ein großer Teil des Geldes abgeflossen in eine, ja es ist relativ komplizierter Quelltext und es gab eine Möglichkeit, wenn man mit dem Verhalten der DAO nicht zufrieden war, konnte man sich sozusagen abspalten und eine Kind-DAO gründen. Und man konnte seinen Anteil an Geld mitnehmen in diese Kind-DAO. Und es gab, wie gesagt, einen Fehler in der Programmcode, der erlaubte, dass man mehr als seinen Anteil mitnehmen konnte.
Also rein rechtlich gesehen alles legal, was der Typ da gemacht hat.
Welches Recht windest du denn an?
Im Prinzip ist das mit dem Buchhalter jetzt passiert.
Man hat eben keine eingebrochen.
Man könnte sogar zugucken, wie das Geld abgeflossen ist.
Genau. Die ISA-Leute sagen jetzt natürlich, das war ein Fehler. Aber man kann natürlich nachträglich auch zu allen möglichen Sachen sagen, das war ein Fehler. Also wer bestimmt jetzt was ein Fehler ist und wer nicht?
Die Mehrheit. Was ist denn jetzt passiert? Dieses Geld ist abgeflossen. Ist es dann irgendwie rückgängig gemacht worden?
Und wie viel Geld reden wir denn?
Genau, also dieses The Dow hat umgerechnet 150 Millionen Dollar an.
Okay.
Also es ist ein richtig schöner Incentive, sich den Code anzugucken, ob der jetzt sicher ist. Also es war eins der teuersten Bug-Bounty-Programme, die ich kenne zumindest.
Wie viel Geld ist abgeflossen?
3, 6 Millionen IFA, das waren ein Drittel ungefähr.
Okay, also man muss immer dazu sagen, der ESA ist zu einem bestimmten Zeitpunkt so und so viel wert und daraus errechnet sich diese Summe. Da hat jetzt niemand irgendwie diese 50 Millionen Dollar auf dem Konto.
Ja, 50 Millionen Dollar, genau. Und die sind dann in diesem Contract gelandet, diesem abgespaltenen Contract. Und dann, der war halt noch timelocked auf 27 Tage, glaube ich.
Ist gerade abgelaufen von ein paar Tagen.
Ja, also innerhalb der 27 Tage konnte er nichts damit machen.
Das ist Teil des Systems.
Ja, genau.
Teil des Systems ist immer sozusagen...
Also das Programm war so geschrieben.
Das Programm war so geschrieben, dass man sozusagen, wenn man eine Transaktion macht, 27 Tage warten muss, bevor man davon profitiert.
Und innerhalb der 27 Tage musste jetzt eine Entscheidung gefällt werden, nämlich die Entscheidung darüber, ob man das einfach so weiterlaufen lässt. Das wäre die, also nichts tun, wäre die eine Möglichkeit gewesen. Dann hätte, ja gut, erst mal nicht die Konsequenzen. Die andere Möglichkeit ist gewesen, eine Abstimmung im Netzwerk zu haben oder zu machen darüber, ob man diese 3, 6 Millionen IFA wieder zurückgibt an die Leute. Also das ist ja alles nur Software. Und basiert auf einem Konsens. Und wenn der Konsens hergestellt ist, dann kann man den auch ändern, wenn die Mehrheit der Meinung ist, dass es okay ist, den Konsens zu ändern, dann kann der geändert werden. Und genau das ist, glaube ich, letzte Woche passiert, dass die Mehrheit gesagt hat, wir wollen das rückgängig machen. Und ich weiß gar nicht, was die Details sind, aber ich nehme an, dass diese 3, 6 Millionen IFA an die Leute zurückgingen, die in The DAO eingezahlt haben. Das ist jetzt meine Vermutung.
Es wurde eine neue Software geschrieben, die eben diese Rückverteilung abgewickelt hat. Da wurde bis jetzt kein Fehler drin gefunden. Und an diese Software wurde dieses Geld einmalig überwiesen.
Aber dann ist jetzt mein Punkt, oder meine Frage wäre dann, es gibt also dieses System, das System, was eigentlich dafür da ist, dass Transaktionen, die stattfinden, nicht mehr rückgängig gemacht werden. Und jetzt ist eine Transaktion stattgefunden, da haben einfach sehr viele Leute gesagt, naja, das gefällt uns jetzt aber nicht, wir machen die doch rückgängig.
Das haben auch nicht alle gesagt, sondern nur ein paar.
Genau, aber das ist ja noch schlimmer sozusagen.
Das System stellt sicher, dass es keine kleine zentrale Stelle gibt, die Manipulationen durchführen kann oder Veränderungen durchführen kann.
Also es konnte jetzt nicht der Hersteller der Software sagen, wir machen das anders und dann ist es anders passiert, sondern es musste sich schon eine Mehrheit finden, die diese geänderte Software dann benutzt.
Das ist klar, aber was ist denn jetzt sozusagen, wenn ich etwas mache, also ich mache sozusagen eine Transaktion in diesem Ethereum, die sozusagen im Sinne des Erfinders ist, also im technischen Sinne des Erfinders, aber alle Leute finden das unmoralisch und sagen dann so, nee, das darf der nicht. Dann laufe ich ja sozusagen...
Es könnte passieren, wenn die Mehrheit sagt, das darf der nicht, dass dann genau das Gleiche passiert.
Das nennt man dann übrigens Hardfork.
Aber das ist ja das ganze System eigentlich hinfällig oder nicht?
Das ist eine relativ aufwendige Sache, so etwas durchzuführen. Und ja, das wird nicht so ohne Weiteres gemacht.
Also da wurde ja auch sehr lange gestritten. Das ist jetzt nicht so eine Entscheidung, die dir ganz leicht gefällt haben, sondern da wurde lange diskutiert und überlegt, ob sie das machen oder nicht. Und ich weiß gar nicht, gibt es da Zahlen zu dem Verhältnis, wie die abgestimmt haben?
Naja, welche Abstimmung weißt du dann? Also es gab mehrere Arten von Abstimmungen. Einmal gab es so eine Art Coin-Vote, wo jeder... Also das Hauptproblem, also vielleicht sollte man auch noch kurz drüber reden, bei diesen dezentralen Anwendungen ist es relativ schwierig, Abstimmungen personenbezogen zu machen. Also es ist schwierig zu sagen, 50% der Personen, die an diesem Netzwerk teilnehmen, haben so und so abgestimmt, weil jeder kann sich zuhause einfach eine neue Identität schaffen. Das ist ja auch gerade das Gute, dass man nicht zu einer zentralen Instanz gehen muss, um sich eine neue Identität oder neue User-Account zu erstellen.
Das ist ja bei Bitcoin auch so. Die Wallets heißt das da. Ich kann ja viele verschiedene Wallets haben.
Die Wallet ist nicht so spannend, aber die Bitcoin-Adressen, dein Konto, davon kannst du ganz viele haben.
Und bei Ethereum ist es auch so, ich kann sozusagen eine Ethereum-Instanz sein, aber ich kann auch irgendwie 20 sein, wenn ich will.
Genau. Wie macht man denn überhaupt Abstimmung, wenn das so ist?
Wenn man einen spezialisierten Contract hat, dann kann man natürlich sagen, es gibt genau diese Personen, und die können jeweils abstimmen. Aber wenn man sagen will, das ganze Netz soll abstimmen, also das ist eine offene Abstimmung, wo jeder teilnehmen kann, dann ist die naheliegende und auch mehr oder weniger die einzige praktikable Möglichkeit, dass man das vom Geldwert abhängig macht.
Was ja aber wieder schlecht ist, wenn der Attacker sich ein Drittel aller Isars geklaut hat, weil dann hat er auch ein Drittel aller Stimmen schon mal.
Hatte er ja noch nicht.
Aber der Abstimmung konnte man das nicht nutzen.
Aber führt das nicht trotzdem dafür, dass man sozusagen so ein total neoliberales System haben, wo die Leute, die am meisten Geld haben, bestimmen, wo es langgeht?
Es gibt auch andere Orten abzustimmen, also man kann auch über die Hashing-Power abstimmen, oder?
Ja, das sind auch die Leute mit dem meisten Geld.
Aber genau deswegen sag ich ja, das ist die einfache und praktikable Methode, die jetzt existiert. Aber wir arbeiten auch daran, es gibt verschiedenste Projekte, die auf Ethereum aufbauen. Und viele davon beschäftigen sich auch damit, wie man Identität regelt und man sich als Person irgendwie identifizieren kann.
Das fällt mir jetzt gerade aus, weil du hattest ja gesagt, das ist mehr als nur Währung. Aber in dem, so wie es momentan funktioniert, wirkt es auf mich tatsächlich wie etwas, was zwar mehr kann als nur Währung hin und her schieben, aber von der Bestimmungskraft immer abhängig davon ist, wer am meisten Kraft, Geld, Währung hat. Aber anders könnte man sagen, diese ganzen dezentralen Systeme, die die Transaktionen immer festschreiben und überwachen, was da passiert ist und sicherstellen, dass es die richtigen Transaktionen sind, könnte man tatsächlich für demokratische Prozesse benutzen. Gibt es da auch Ideen?
Na, es ist ja nicht anonym. Insofern ist es schwierig, das für Parlamentswahlen. Jedenfalls, wenn man den Anspruch hat, dass anonym gewählt werden können soll, dann wäre das nicht geeignet.
Es wird an solchen Sachen auch geforscht. Abstimmungen auf der Blockchain sind transparent, müssen sie ja auch sein, damit man sozusagen die Stimmauszellung nachvollziehen kann. Aber es gibt sogenannte Zero-Knowledge-Verfahren, die das Ganze trotzdem anonymisieren können. Das ist ein relativ kompliziertes mathematisches Verfahren, wo man sozusagen die Korrektheit der Stimmauszellung überprüfen kann, ohne die Stimmen wirklich zu sehen.
Das alles ist sozusagen schon noch im Experimentierstadium. Okay, da sind 150 Millionen Dollar drin. Das ist ganz schön viel, aber ich vermute, so wie sich das anhört, der Zustand der Software, ist es noch Beta oder nicht?
Ich weiß gar nicht, ob es offiziell noch Beta ist.
Genau, was man auch sagen muss, die Plattform selbst ist nicht im Beta-Stadium. Und das war ja auch kein Fehler der Plattform. Aber Anwendungen, die auf der Plattform erstellt werden, da muss man immer schauen, wie...
Wie es war kein Fehler der Plattform? Das verwirrt mich jetzt doch. Wenn es kein Fehler der Plattform war, warum wurde es dann rückgängig gemacht? Was war es für ein Fehler?
Es war ein Fehler in einem Programm, das auf der Plattform erstellt wurde.
Aber wie kann das denn ein Fehler sein? Es geht doch nur darum, dass das Programm auf der Plattform ausgeführt wird und dass es sichergestellt wird, dass alle dasselbe Ergebnis rausbekommen. Das verstehe ich jetzt tatsächlich nicht so ganz.
Deswegen wurde ja abgestimmt. Viele waren mit der Meinung, das war kein Fehler. Sondern der Typ hat halt eine Schwäche ausgenutzt, aber die war ja nun mal da so rein design, hat sich einer vertan, aber es war halt Teil von dem Konstrukt und hat sich ausgenutzt.
Also der eigentliche Fehler war aber, das Programm, was in das Ethereum reingetan wurde, hat nicht so funktioniert, wie die Macher sich das gedacht haben. Aber das Ethereum hat korrekt funktioniert.
Genau.
Das verwirrt mich jetzt nochmal nachhaltig, weil das ja wirklich sagen bedeutet, dass das Ethereum eigentlich funktioniert, aber dass man sich nicht sicher ist, ob man das wirklich genauso will.
Naja, das mit dem Zurückrollen, wenn man das nicht gemacht hätte, dann wäre es schwer gewesen, Vertrauen in dieses System zu erhalten. Man kann natürlich umgekehrt... Na ja, ich meine, da wurde...
Was ich auch sagen kann, ist, dass war ein relativ großes Ereignis für die gesamte Community. Und hat wahrscheinlich auch viele so ein bisschen wachgerüttelt, sich den Programmcode nochmal genauer anzuschauen, mehr Arbeit reinzustecken und so weiter.
Also nicht nur das Programmcode von Ethereum, sondern von den Programmen, die da drauflaufen?
Genau, genau. Und hat auch viele Projekte jetzt nochmal befeuert, die so in die Richtung gehen, dass man sichere Software schreibt, dass man Software verifiziert und so weiter. Also wir haben jetzt auch ein, also das Projekt gab es schon länger, aber er hat jetzt nochmal mehr Schub bekommen, dass man formale Verifikationen betreibt. Das heißt, man benutzt Software, die andere Software verifiziert. Also mit mathematischen Verfahren prüft, ob ein Programm wirklich das tut, was man denkt, dass es tut.
Also mit Verlaub, ich würde nichts auf Ethereum machen. Das wirkt mir noch sehr, das wirkt so ein bisschen wie die Leute, die das machen, wissen vielleicht selber gar nicht mehr so ganz genau, was da passiert. Und ich finde es momentan, so wie es sich anhat, finde ich es noch ein bisschen, weiß ich nicht genau, ob das, also ich finde es total spannend als Experiment, aber ich würde zum Beispiel keine 150 Millionen Dollar rein investieren.
Ich meine, es kann ja jeder für sich entscheiden, wie viel Geld in dieses Projekt steckt. Und diese 150 Millionen, ich weiß nicht, ich meine, es waren auch sehr viele Leute beteiligt. Aber jeder hat da nur einen relativ kleinen Betrag investiert.
Wir haben noch eine kurze Hörerfrage. Christopher nochmal. Du wolltest ja wissen, warum, wenn die Transaktionen bei Bitcoin und Ethereum transparent sind, warum das sozusagen dann von Kriminellen gerne genutzt wird. Die Frage wurde eigentlich gerade schon beantwortet. Hast du es mitbekommen? Na ja, wir haben gerade darüber geredet, dass ja sozusagen in Bitcoin und Ethereum sozusagen keine Personen agieren, sondern in dieser Software, in diesen Blockchains, agieren immer nur Adressen.
Und diese Pseudonym.
Alledem geht es ja immer von irgendeiner IP aus.
Aber Bitcoin kann man auch über das Tornennetzwerk benutzen. Aber der Knackpunkt ist natürlich, irgendwann willst du deine Bitcoin in Euros oder in irgendwas anderes, was man in die Hand nehmen kann, irgendwie tauschen. Und dann gibt es einen, wie sagt man, Interface zur realen Welt, also eine Verbindung in die echte Welt. Und dann kann man dich ja doch wieder zurückverfolgen. Also man kann mit Bitcoin schon ein bisschen tricksen, aber man muss halt schon irgendwie aufpassen. Also wenn du sehr anonym bleiben willst, dann solltest du deine Bitcoins halt über Tor tauschen und das Geld dann mit irgendjemanden Unbekannten auf der Straße den Deal machen. Und nicht über Konten oder so.
Verständnisfrage, weil ist ja nun mal Fakt, dass die Währung natürlich nutzt wird. Aber großartig aus meiner Sicht passieren tut ja da echt nicht viel. Na ja, so wie ich verstanden bin, durch München jetzt erst würde Darknet mal wieder so ein bisschen eine Ohre, das ist neu, das ist Darknet.
Ja, aber das legt sich auch wieder.
Also Bitcoin ist nicht anonym, sondern pseudonym, wenn eine Verbindung zwischen der Bitcoin-Adresse und einer realen Person hergestellt wird, weil man die auf seiner eigenen Webseite veröffentlicht, zum Beispiel, oder weil man jemandem die sagt, dem man sie vielleicht nicht hätte sagen sollen, dann ist man identifizierbar mit dieser Adresse, wenn man selber die Verbindung herstellt.
Genau, aber man kann sozusagen, man kann sie sich dafür benutzen.
Unsere Hörer können ja mal zu blockchain.infosurfen, und da ist ein JavaScript oder was auch immer so ein Ticker programmiert. Da kann man jede einzelne Transaktion, die gerade im Bitcoin-Netzwerk passiert, die scrollt da so durch. Da kann man richtig live zugucken, was in diesem Bitcoin-Netzwerk gerade los ist, damit man ein Verständnis dafür hat, wie transparent das ist.
Okay, dann Christopher hoffe ich, wir konnten dir auch diese Frage noch beantworten. Dann viel Spaß noch. Und wir sind jetzt gleich schon am Ende der Sendung angekommen. Ich danke Dennis, Dirk und Christian, dass sie hier waren. Ich würde noch gerne wissen, ganz zum Schluss und ganz kurz, was wird eure präferierte Zahlungsmethode in 10 Jahren sein? Dennis?
Digital.
Na ja, digital, ach nee. Aber welche Form? Blockchain?
Das ist mir eigentlich fast wurscht. Hauptsache, es geht schnell und easy und ich muss nicht viel machen und man kann es mir nicht klauen.
Ich hoffe auf Zero Cash. Das wird dann tatsächlich anonyme Transaktionen ermöglichen, wenn es das hält, was es momentan für schon gibt.
Also Zero Cash ist ein konkretes Projekt.
Ja, da gibt es noch kein Mainnet zu, aber in zehn Jahren sind sie dann hoffentlich, ich hab jetzt schon seit fünf Jahren davon gehört, mal gucken, ob sie dann in zehn Jahren so weit sind.
Alles klar, Christian?
Ich bin jetzt dieses Zero Knowledge, von dem wir schon auch gesprochen haben.
Christian, wie willst du dein Eis bezahlen?
Eine Zahlungsmethode, bei der keine Daten über mich gesammelt werden können und die trotzdem schnell und praktisch ist.
Alles klar, wir werden dann sagen, in zehn Jahren an dieser Stelle vielleicht wieder drüber sprechen, womit wir gerade...
In zehn Jahren wollen wir alle Bargeld haben, gibt es nicht mehr.
Ich bin ja eh großer Fan von Shine. Vorerst wird es auch noch so bleiben. Liebe Gäste, ich danke euch, dass ihr so geduldig mit mir wart und alles schön erklärt habt. Liebe Hörer, ich danke fürs Zuhören. Wenn ihr es nochmal genau nachvollziehen wollt, auf fritz.de erscheint in dieser Nacht noch der Podcast. Wenig später auch mit Video auf chaosradio.ccc.de. Ansonsten könnt ihr im nächsten Monat in die Marienstraße 11 zum Chaos Computer Club kommen. Dort gibt es auch ein Chaos Radio, das nicht über Fritz gesendet wird. Da gibt es dann wieder in zwei Monaten eine Sendung. Mein Name ist Marcus Richter und mir bleibt nur noch eine Sache zu sagen, ne zwei. Die eine ist, jetzt gibt es gleich Gitarrenmusik mit Jan Schwarzkamp im Nightfly. Und die andere ist, lasst euch nicht überwachen und macht immer schön eure Backups. Don't forget I'm in your extended network, biatch!